over the weekend if like the entire
country was watching television
slack-jawed as the impossible happened
the taliban swept into kabul afghanistan
no matter how you feel about the
occupation we were very against it
you had to ask yourself how did this
happen and why wasn't america prepared
for it happening
most people reached the obvious
conclusion they've been lying to us
about the state of affairs in
afghanistan really lying to us for a
long time and by they we mean not just
political figures for people the state
department the secretary of state
multiple secretaries of state
and an awful lot of generals at the
pentagon they haven't been telling us
the truth
now most people including everyone on
this show are pretty shocked by that but
not everyone was shocked glenn greenwald
has been chronicling this for a long
time he's an independent journalist who
writes on sub stack you can read his
stuff there and you should he joins us
tonight glenn thanks so much for coming
on on this and many other subjects i
will say uh you've been right you've
been proved right so you were not
surprised to learn that their
assessments of what was happening on the
ground in afghanistan were totally false
absolutely you know i grew up one of the
big events in my childhood that chaped
me a lot were the pentagon papers when
danny ellsberg inside the government
leaked to newspapers the fact that the
statements being made by the military
about the war in vietnam were winning we
have the viet cong on the run where the
exact opposite of what they were saying
internally which is there's no way we
could possibly win this war the best we
can do as a stalemate the same thing
happened
in afghanistan but even worse the
argument that was being made all the way
back to george bush was the goal that we
have and we're making great progress is
building an afghan national security
force that will protect the government
and democracy and be able to ward off
the taliban and that way we can leave
when they stand on their own feet which
they're very close to doing internally
for 20 years they were saying the afghan
national forces are a joke they're
corrupt they're illiterate they have no
capacity to fight whatsoever and five
weeks ago joe biden stood before the
country and said the afghan national
forces are way more powerful than the
taliban it's extremely unlikely that the
taliban will overrun the country when we
leave when all intelligence and all
internal documents showed exactly the
opposite it's not a case where they got
it wrong in good faith it's a case where
they deliberately lie to the public to
justify this endless war because so many
people were profiting from it
so that i mean i think you answered the
question i was about to ask which is why
would you lie about something
that everybody is going to learn about
in the end like they had to know they
were going to get caught lying because
in the end the taliban did sweep into
kabul why so you think they lied because
people were profiting from this exercise
this debacle
yeah the last time i was on your show
one of the last times we talked about
why americans should be spending their
resources to fix the government of cuba
the whole point of america first as
articulated by donald trump was we
should focus on american citizens why
should american
citizens risk their lives
to determine how kandahar is governed
when instead americans aren't being
governed very well at all and life
expectancy and every other indicia of
happiness is declining and the reason is
because there's a tiny segment of people
certain people in the corporate media
whose ratings go up and also the defense
contractors who fund both parties who
make a lot of power and a lot of profit
as do the security state services the
pentagon the cia the nsa when there's
war and that's what happens is you know
propaganda is really powerful right we
see these images of these people
desperately trying to get afghanistan
and there's a tendency to say oh i want
the u.s to go back and save them but you
know we don't see all the people we've
killed in afghanistan who are innocent
civilians that just happens in war and
they control the information that we see
to keep us always wanting the next war
and to forget what we learned about the
prior ones
god that's so true
if you'd said this five years it'd be
like ah glenn greenwald nice guy a
little kooky now i i i think you've been
proven right again glenn greenwald thank
you very much
thanks tucker good to be with you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else